about
um yeah so my wife's minimalist so you
know I guess I caught on a little and
this this talk is gonna be so much about
minimalism that there's no results uh
just just some opinions
um all right
so you know typically In classical
crypto there's this refrain that one-way
functions are the minimal cryptographic
assumption you know we've put in our
theorem statements from the minimal
Assumption of all my functions blah blah
blah
um and this is just uh you know taking
this fact
uh so we can uh view things uh by
looking at crypto Mountain where we have
you know all the Primitives you might
care about
um up in space there we have obfuscation
and other ones in case you missed it
um and uh you know we typically treat
one like functions as being on the
bottom of this mountain
um however a pretty cool sequence of
Works
um has shown that actually there's
something below one-way functions once
we enter Quantum
um and and so there's this you know
whole C now of of these
less than one-way function uh
computational assumptions that uh we
could plausibly make uh in in the
quantum space and
um
the the point of this talk is to just
explore what should be the new minimal
Quantum crypto assumption
so um actually most of this talk is
going to have nothing to do with Quantum
at all
um and what I'm going to do for the bulk
of it is review
what what what I think of are the
reasons that make one of my functions
minimal uh for classical crypto and once
we have those reasons uh maybe we can
start to you know try to understand what
what to look for in the quantum setting
okay so the the obvious uh thing to
start from is just the and I'll call
this feature zero is that one of my
functions are implied by essentially
everything in crypto so you know in in a
in a feasibility sense they they are
minimal because if you can do anything
you can do one-way functions at least
anything in the computational setting
um but this is not satisfying because
you know one of the the famous results
from symmetrici crypto is that one-way
functions are actually uh really
powerful in the sense that we can we can
we can if we have wanted functions we
can do almost all symmetric crypto and
we can even do some publicly crypto like
signatures uh so what is stopping us
from calling uh signatures the minimal
crypto assumption why don't we have all
of our theorem statements say from the
minimal Assumption of signatures
um so now I want to describe a handful
of features that one-way functions have
that you know all of these other things
you know may or may not have that I
think really make one of my functions a
a nice thing to be kind of the central
Hub that we call a minimal assumption
so I'm going to first update feature
zero to feature one and I want that
um whatever object we're talking about
in order for it to be minimal not only
is it implied by almost everything but
it should actually be rather trivially
implied by almost everything
um so for example going for one-way
functions to signatures is extremely
complex relies on a number of uh really
foundational
um and surprising results in classical
cryptography you have wanted functions
of pseudonym generators from there you
go to prf's
um you then you have uh you know the
signature trees and all that it's really
quite a complex construction so it's
highly non-trivial to go for one-way
functions to signatures but almost
everything
rather trivially implies one-way
functions
um this isn't quite true
um really uh the the really obvious way
that you would try to get a one-way
function from a lot of cryptographic
Primitives is really it only gives you a
distributional one-way function which
says that
um it's so it's a different requirement
it's not that
um
it's hard to invert but it's actually
hard to sample from the distribution of
pre-images
um so almost everything trivially gives
you a distributional one-way function
it's pretty close to a one-way function
though and and they they do imply each
other uh so so this is this one's a
little bit hand wavy I guess
um but you know again like the goal is
to find something where you're not
having to do this enormous complex uh
uh thing to try to build your assumption
from the rest of crypto it should just
be really direct and simple
something
other countries have very low complexes
um sure sure
um I mean just deliver it
[Music]
even compared to distribution Runway
functions are much easier to tell
somebody about it yeah yeah now all the
world can touch on that on I have
several more features to go and we'll uh
number of complexity but those are kind
of touched on
um okay so closely related
um is when we're actually going to not
just instantiate from other General
crypto Summers but when we actually want
to instantiate from concrete assumptions
again we want it to be trivially implied
by most concrete assumptions
um and it's you know it's trivial that
discrete log factoring learning with
theirs is like almost any crypto
assumption that you might want to use
um trivially implies one of my functions
it actually implies one of my functions
not you know having to go through
distribution along my functions
um and in contrast if you want to go
from like discrete log to signatures and
you don't care and you don't want random
oracles you have to work pretty hard
um another another uh sort of
um sub Feature Feature two is that I
want the the implication to be rather
robust and I think looking at discrete
log versus ddh is a good example of this
um so the fact that the screen so the
discrete log is a one-way function
that's that's
um rather trivial but it's one way
function even if you kind of play around
with the the function a little right if
you sample X uniformly in the
um domain of exponents it's still one
way if you sample X uniformly as n bit
strings where n is log of P it's still
one way
um if you choose X from a a subgroup of
the exponent space as long as it's
almost everything it's still one way
um
I mean the regular notion of when I
functions from my functions
um and contrast this with ddh where the
whether or not the Assumption holds is
really sensitive to the distribution
right if you're if you're working on in
the
um you know the multiplicative group mod
P DH is false if you actually choose
your exponents uniformly in in Z sub P
minus one you have to you have to make
sure that you uh you know are in a
subgroup like here so
um what we want is something is a way to
go from our algebraic crypto assumptions
uh to whatever our minimal assumption is
in a way that's relatively robust the
changes they're not not super sensitive
to the details
okay so here's um the simple to Define
one of my functions are really easy to
find I can you know Define them in one
line
um whereas like digital signatures you'd
have to have this little interactive
game and all that
sorry
um another one is we want it to be
falsifiable uh and you know there's
subtly different Notions of
falsifiability in the literature but I'm
going to take the sort of
um
in precise version which is just it's
defined by an interactive game between
an adversary and Challenger
um so are signatures so are most of the
things we care about but things like uh
musics or whatnot would not fall into
this category
um related to some of the things before
uh we would like a search problem uh
generally search problems are milder
assumptions than the corresponding and
distinguishability assumption the more
robust as we saw with the discrete log
versus DEH example uh so search problems
um are probably you know more likely to
be minimal than a decision problem
um here's another one uh maybe this one
is optional I don't know
why why is it obvious that search
I mean it's it's not obvious I guess in
um just on the face of it but at least
as it relates to some of these other
things we would want uh you know search
search assumptions are are more robust
um they tend to be milder right like
discrete log is as a milder assumption
than ddh
uh and also they often tend to be
simpler I guess
so
here's another one
um so combiners so with one of my
functions if you have uh if you have two
candidate one of functions and you
don't know whether they're secure but
you have the guarantee that at least one
of them is secure it's trivial to get a
one-way function that's guaranteed to be
secure as long as you know at least one
of the input one-way functions is secure
what do you do you just uh your your
input is now an input uh is two inputs
right it's a pair one input for the one
one-way function that should be F2 over
there
um another input for the other one-way
function and if you can invert this new
combined woman function then uh clearly
you're actually inverting both one-way
functions so as long as one of the two
is hard then
um the this combined when we function is
hard and this feature of having a
combiner allows you to actually get
something that's called a universal
warning function which is a single fixed
one-way function that is secure as long
as there exists a one-way function that
is secure you don't know what it is but
as long as there is someone in my
function that's secure this uh gold
record one-way function will be a secure
one-way function
I'm sorry to keep doing this but I think
that's actually a resultantly an 11. I
see okay almost earlier
I see I blindly am copying uh citations
from other works and apparently I don't
know about the the previous one but this
one I definitely copied from a paper
yeah
which sites
um
let's put it this way I think better
than a child
yeah I I actually I was curious I asked
Ted GPT to Define
um instinishability obfuscation and it
came up with something that like kind of
sort of looked okay if you skimmed it
but it was was actually totally wrong
one too actually
so so chat TPT definitely doesn't
understand crypto yeah
um okay so
um so this is this is a nice feature and
and what it does is it actually makes
one of my functions a nice Hub and
allows us to use um the one-way function
combiner to actually get a combiner for
a lot of symmetric crypto you want to
combine it for pseudonym generators well
you you got one right you go through one
of my functions you want a combiner for
pseudorado permutations signatures
whatever you got one you go through only
functions and the interesting thing is
in that a lot of these cases it's
this is the only way we know how to get
a universal construction we don't know
how to get a universal construction of
say pseudorandom permutations uh
directly there's there's uh there's as
far as I know anyway there's no direct
construction of a pseudo random
permutation that's Universal
oh we can do it because we can go
through all my functions
um and then so this is going to be uh
related to the previous one and also
about Simplicity
um we really want uh like we want there
to be a definition that really has a
there's a security property and kind of
nothing else right and if you think
about things like signatures pseudonym
permutations uh what not there there are
they're they're correctness properties
right uh signature we need that there's
this verification algorithm that
verified signatures student
implementations we need that the
functions of permutation and also that
there's an efficient inversion algorithm
uh whereas one of my functions there's
really nothing we require that we
require deterministic procedure that
that's that's basically it
um classical determinants procedure
um
uh prgs uh are are basically requiring
nothing except we we do need the the
function to be expanding so there's like
a little tiny requirement uh but yeah
pseudorant permutations
um
that's pretty strong correctness
requirement and and this is actually
related to
um the previous point about universality
that if you have two so if you have two
pseudorado permutations let's say and
you're guaranteed that they're both
functionally pseudo-rounded permutation
oh sorry you're guarantee that they're
both permutations functionally that
there's an f and an F inverse and they
actually invert each other then it is
actually trivial to combine them you can
just compose them
um and and you're done uh but the
problem is for Universal construction
you you actually need not just that you
can combine the security but you you
sort of need that you can identify when
an algorithm actually satisfies the
correctness requirements
um and and so so really what helps for
getting uh Universal construction is
that your
um all your Corrections requirements are
semantic oh yes would you say that
security amplification is also an
important feature
um yes I didn't I didn't put that in
here but uh yes that is a good feature
as well to have
uh right so so
um
right and so having so one of my
functions the only security the only
correctness property is semantic just
deterministic classical function
and what this allows you to do uh is you
can actually enumerate all possible
classical deterministic functions and
this is really crucial to getting this
Universal Construction
um and in contrast
um you know there's no way to enumerate
all possible pseudorendum permutations
I will point out that you
you know this is not a necessary
condition for there to be a universal
construction you know for example we can
get Universal construction of prps by
going through all my functions
um or there's you know we have Universal
constructions of indistinguishability
obfuscation that are our direct from an
extinguishability obfuscation they're
very complex though and
um you know there's like several papers
to actually get them
um but I guess the point is though that
having a minimal correctness requirement
really helps make the uh Universal
construction much uh nicer
okay and then the the last feature is uh
well kind of the maybe one I should have
started with which is that it's actually
useful that you can build crypto from it
uh we don't want something that's way
beneath uh crypto Mountain here that
doesn't that's totally useless for
crypto
um so you know this is obviously a
crucial feature you know if I can I can
define a minimal assumption that is
implied by everything but doesn't do
anything at all and there's kind of a
point
okay so um I don't want to step on oh
yes
I call feed shop only functions and it's
a social reason it's defining difficult
and it's a lot of attractions but that's
why so I think one-way function is
turn off turn off and yeah that could
totally happen too in the quantum space
if you know Common enough paper sort of
uh claims to have the minimal assumption
I think right now the main Contender are
the EFI repairs
um
uh
but I I think also one of my functions
do have a lot of nice properties
um that even if you know if it wasn't
defined by famous people maybe you would
have converged on it anyway
um so I don't want to step on any of the
other talks today so I'm going to just
talk about two examples of less than
one-way function Quantum
um objects
uh and and see how they share so so the
first one is pseudo-random States so
this was defined by GE Liu and song
um and I I think at the time they didn't
actually claim anything about being
beneath one-way functions it was kind of
realized after the fact I could be wrong
but uh
um the point of their work was to find
this object not necessarily to explore
the below one-way function space But
nevertheless this emerges kind of an
early example
so what is a pseudorandom Quantum state
uh so it's kind of like a pseudor random
generator except that the output is a as
a Quantum state so we have this um
Quantum procedure G that takes as input
a classical seed and outputs a Quantum
State and I'm just going to call the
input length Lambda on the output length
and qubits and I'm not going to Define
security precisely but we want that the
output state looks random even under
polynomially many copies of the state
right in Quantum land we have this no
cloning theorem which means that if you
want to have multiple copies of
something you actually need to be
provided them you can't get you can't
get them for yourself
um and you know as you manipulate them
you might accidentally destroy them so
having multiple copies potentially gives
the adversary more power to uh
right
um and now it turns out that for this
um you need crypto uh as you know for a
classical student generator you need
crypto as long as n is greater than
Lambda
um for sit around States it's a little
different basically because the you know
the space here is um you know there's an
extra exponential in the head space of a
Quantum State uh so really you need
crypto as long as n is greater than log
Lambda and if and only if there's a
there's a tight threshold
um
right okay so so what how does it fare
against my criteria uh so trivially
implied by General Primitives this is
this is not true
um so the the constructions we have go
through pseudorandom functions
um and I think they all go through three
different functions certainly the
original ones the
um and this required you know not only
something like gold Rec 11 and construct
and uh uh you know gdm and all that to
get classical pseudonym
um functions but actually needed to be
secure against Quantum queries uh which
means you need a Quantum version of gold
rack 11 you need a Quantum proof of uh
ggm which
um you know all these require their own
papers
um similarly it's not trivially and
robustly implied by uh any concrete
assumption
as far as I know
um
it is pretty simple it's not you know as
simple as a one-way function you have
you know this polynomially many copies
business uh but it's pretty simple it is
certainly falsifiable pretty much all
the proposals out there are falsifiable
this one's easy to satisfy
um yeah
I think that's written in JLS it's not
clear how you falsify right
that's true I imagine you can yeah yeah
I imagine you can you
sample things efficiently and yeah okay
fair enough so so even falsifiables a
question mark here
um I was giving them too much credit uh
yes
um
it's the state
um are you have a way of producing the
state yes this is the G here so then if
you're given the G you should be able to
make any number of copies right so in
the security experiment so you're either
given polynomial any copies of this or
you're given polynomial many copies of a
of a random State and that's the that's
the part that is not necessarily trivial
um so it's a sample
still with us
just because it takes it takes you you
can't write down a random State and then
you finite Precision uh it's kind of a
simple reason why you can't do this
yeah so so the one side of the
experiment where you're producing these
is easy it's the it's the other side
that's on the side that that kind of
plays a role of the random string in the
prg definition
um a search problem is it's uh it fails
it's a decision problem
um confiners and Universal constructions
there's no idea
um and in fact it's actually
um non-trivial or even not even known to
go between
um uh sooner and states of different
output lines
correctness requirements we're kind of
in the same domain as as uh appearance
here there's you know one correctness
requirements
okay
the procedure and useful
um you know their applications to want
money and other things
yes this is possible that the first two
are actually many of these things are
just because we don't know Quantum well
enough yet we don't know how to do
things trivially we didn't maybe there
are tricks possibly yeah it's certainly
possible yeah yeah
um absolutely
um I I will say they're not combiners
what was that how can you come back I
can't I can't yeah this is yeah
certainly this is based on the current
state of knowledge but you know if the
classical crypto has much more you know
many more years of experience absolutely
absolutely but think but thinking of one
and two for example
um you know like any undergraduate in a
crypto class if you ask them to
construct a one-way function from you
know Diggy Helmet or something they'd
probably be able to figure it out
um whereas
I I I I wouldn't have known
[Laughter]
and require like a whole body of Prior
work in order to get pseudorandom uh
States
I like this direction but I think you
should give the same talk in 20 years
yeah yeah yeah absolutely so yeah these
are these are absolutely based on like
the current state of knowledge
is useful
it's useful
um
why do we begin with sex we think this
is more minimal dialogue so
um uh
well basically we we know that there's a
black box separation that you can't get
um they you you camped in a black box so
you build one of my functions from
student States and yeah one of my
functions apply suit around stage so
just from a feasibility perspective
these live below one of my functions and
the the question is okay they live below
one of my functions maybe now we can
have you know a whole bunch of cool
feasibility results that don't rely on
my functions but rely on something even
less or potentially even less than like
you know P like maybe P equals NP and
you can still do crypto
um
so that that's that's why people are are
looking at these and yeah and we have we
have a we have black box separations
that show that these things
yeah but this is yeah but like you said
you're getting the example with
signatures this is all very like what's
below what right like for example you
can construct this from let's say
um crh but you cannot construct crh like
but we know
yeah yeah certainly some things can be
incomparable right yeah but this is more
complicated right it's like somehow you
can require less assumptions and still
be more complicated so there's it seems
like there's maybe multiple Dimensions
here that you yeah I mean the the whole
my dream is that there is a primitive
out there
that just is obviously implied by you
know all Sudan States if I pair is
anything you name it trivial implied by
it it's useful for crypto and you know
maybe satisfies like a number of these
other requirements simple has combiners
whatnot would you have like Superman
States more if you could construct them
sort of directly for one-way functions
without going to without going through
uh PR code yes yes
uh but as it's as it stands like you
know if if things were out of order and
people and Quantum had been hot in the
in the 70s or something like people
would be not causing this and thinking
that this is stronger than only
functions potentially
right yeah this is yeah this does not
look minimal I think yeah I agree I
agree even though you know from a
feasibility perspective it's less than
one-way functions I I agree I don't
think
and you know this is you know my attempt
at least partially explaining one yeah
is
certainly some of these Primitives I
don't know about all of them mark what
was the question the question is is
whether you can have P equals NP in like
suit around States exist I think you can
like stay tuned right yeah yeah
yeah
you know like I I certainly not the
foremost expert in this area and I know
it it it's it's very it's moving very
quickly and it's very complex right now
um that's why I'm not gonna go I can't
claim that like everything that you
follow my functions can exist of people
than me and it's it's rather than once
uh but certainly some things can exist
um yeah okay so this is the last I'm
only going to talk about two things uh
here's the other one uh wait uh so
one-way State generator
um so this was proposed by Mormon Paulo
and the the motivation is you know okay
the pseudonym states are kind of like
pseudoran generators uh one of my
functions are you know more minimal than
student generators in some Dimensions at
least
um so let's try to get a one-way
function like object that's related to
pseudonym States so this is what they
came up with
um the the issue with
um one-way State generators is just that
it becomes
um
all right so it becomes non-trivial to
actually Define
um what it means to invert the one-way
State generators in a meaningful way
because you you could have it just that
it's information theoretically
um uninvertible
um for example this is what Quantum
money gives you
so so you so they they had to Define
this extra verification procedure that
takes as input a a state and a candidate
for what the original classical input
was and then accepts a Rejects
I could uh
photography on them or something like
this
photography requires uh you know because
the dimension is huge here right I don't
think it's trivial though yes
um
but uh
in general it's not obviously okay I
don't know why is this implied by
General on their money
um I I take it back it's not it's just
just the fact just the fact that
um
uh you could have information theoretic
again
right but is this implied by public key
on the money which cannot be information
yeah uh I I don't that's a fantastic
question so you know most of the study
of
um of this like less than one-way
function crypto has focused on on things
like building commitments and stuff like
that and it to me intuitively at least
it seems like it's relying on a
different source of hardness than things
like public key points
so maybe not even number one should yeah
um yeah yeah it might not be
um you know but sometimes you know at
least implied by most possible so it
doesn't play by a lot of teams yeah
maybe not some other things
um I also don't think it's applied by
commitments
um
but you know okay maybe this would be a
question mark or something
um so also concrete assumptions give
these
um this I would say is not simple though
it's uh you know it has this
um has this extra correctness
requirements it is a search problem
um but because of this correctness
requirements
um and maybe other reasons also there's
no combiners so it's none that we know
of or
um
for example
I would say the definition of c is not
equal to energy is not simple if you
just give the formal definition without
any explanation but it is
because we understand that it says
something very sure sure
I don't know it's just a comment like
how would you consider the definition of
uh peace are the worst case I don't know
he's not equal to NP how would you be
consider it simple or not
um relatively maybe not as simple as one
of my functions I don't know
um
whatever or verify or something yeah
yeah fair enough fair enough
um
yeah so I think it's simple based on
understanding because we understand what
it means it is simple so maybe you know
I guess what will it take for this to be
you know really simple like you're
already starting off the bat with with
like a security requirement and a
correctness requirement it's already
more complicated than say one of the
functions
and yeah maybe maybe some context would
help with that
um but I don't know I I guess I'm
skeptical but but yeah you're absolutely
right that maybe these things get easier
if we develop a sort of better
understanding of what what's going on
um and that's really it I just wanted to
leave this with the possibility
um that maybe there actually isn't a
good minimal crypto assumption
um that you know maybe actually the
beneath One Way function domain is is
going to be a mess and it's inherently a
mess and we're never going to fix it
maybe it's not true there are no
assumptions or or maybe there's no
assumption
um all right and that's it thank you
okay
if there are any more quick questions
um
[Music]
I imagine there's some some analogy
besides
that's good
[Applause]
thank you